so many of us have seen the teaser clips
to godzilla vs kong that was recently
released this january
and in it was the clearer version of the
one that was leaked in 2019
the scene where kong punches gaza right
on top of an aircraft carrier
with that in mind two questions
immediately came up
one how could two monsters stand on top
of an aircraft carrier without it
sinking
well we have done a video on it and to
check it out after this one
the second question the focal point of
this video right now
is how tall is kong and or is kong
taller than godzilla
well we have properly assessed the video
and with not so impressive editing
techniques we have come to a conclusion
originally godzilla 2014 from legendary
pictures was scaled to be 108.2 meters
or 355 feet tall and was stated to weigh
90 000 metric tons
making it the largest film version at
that time in a 2019 movie godzilla king
of the monsters he has grown
taller and heavier his height was now
119.8 meters
or 393 feet tall his stay length was 582
feet long
and so if combined with the rest of his
body he would have a total length of
around
800 feet godzilla vs kong is said to be
two years after the events of king of
the monsters so godzilla's sides would
have barely changed
that is if legendary doesn't pull the
wool over our eyes and we get a smaller
version
so what about gom in the earlier movies
kong 2017 was a very large monster even
though compared to godzilla and the
other titans at that time
he was very small this gong was designed
to be 104 feet tall
to give him a weight of only 158 tons
therefore kong was increased in size to
200 feet plus in the comics birth of
gong
and now as we have seen in deezer he
would be close to
if not a little bit taller than godzilla
so a height of around 380 to 400 feet
tall
but this is just an estimate and is this
estimate correct
let us see what happens in a teaser
trailer we can actually see him being
half a head taller than godzilla
when he punches the g-man so let the
pseudo science commence so here we have
a screenshot of the teaser
clearly we can see two things one
godzilla is kinda crouching a bit
and kong's legs aren't straight plus he
was throwing a punch which means
his height is a bit lower than when he
stands straight so given that
we know godzilla is 393 feet tall let us
put him aside and focus
just on the giant ape one thing is clear
kong is no longer an adolescent growing
up to be like the other titans
he is now an alpha himself so let us
straighten up kong's posture
and make him stand straight yeah just
about right as you can see
the heads are the same size which means
the height of gong is yes
taller than when he is throwing that
punch okay now how do we do this
comparing him to the g-man well that
seems to be the obvious thing to do but
we don't know how much crouch godzilla
is
making kong's posture is easier since he
is bipedal
and the iraq poster is all too familiar
to us humans
now we are going to compare kong
alongside the aircraft carrier
this warship is the biggest in the world
it is a gerald r4
carrier which is in service with the us
navy
this ship is 337 meters or 1106 feet
long
therefore we need to get it scaled with
numbers visually
okay let us rotate and measure kong
alongside the ship and the scaling
now what we have here is gong when
standing straight
he stands to be 400 feet tall well
roughly so
kong isn't taller or shorter than
godzilla he is the same height
therefore making this future fight even
more interesting
and with that we come to the end of the
video do click that subscribe button and
be a part of the mind cue family
while you're at it do check out our
teespring store and also smash that
notification bell for regular updates on
future videos
take care fam